welcome to this video playing zut r 1999
from the US now maybe a grünfeld
don't play that often but okay after
this I always found this ideas funny
with castles sacrificing a pawn but I
came this is the tried and tested
mainline okay yeah this I don't really
know wow it's there there's some point
to play on page six first take this
Queen III and queen of form I don't know
come on h6 shouldn't be too bad
what is this this is a secret a peace
sacrifice or that's hard to believe
really I can't even take with the Queen
hmm check
so I'm a piece up forwards to pawns in
amazing
okay the ship is maybe coming to see
form but I can take g2 maybe maybe this
is an idea to make it a bit more
difficult for him to castle
yeah of course the 636 but I thought
Quincy five could be a good idea quickly
attacking the bishop and preparing rook
e8 attacking III yeah no this he can
give this check but I just play king of
eight and nothing much happens
yeah that's rookie three with Bishop
deform I wonder this threatening
threatening rookie to double-check this
should should be should be quite good
but um but it's a tablet check check
Queen f2 check
so where's the maid here's the right
check white resign you should have six
maid next that was that was quick yeah
but a very strange very strange opening
I mean this is not strange I have played
this myself but I normally just played
Nydia three back here because it's
normally not avoidable anyway yeah this
I really don't I don't know I know that
it is it is existing but don't know any
any details but here I thought just not
have three back but this is just too
strange I don't think that this is can
be a check enough compensation it's just
I mean I'm not far behind in development
and it's just two pounds so now probably
probably this is still the better choice
and tending d6 check this is in a blitz
game there are still practical chance to
see em it's quite clear I think black
should be better but so it still needs
to be played and forever is just an
additional weakness yeah and here while
the computer wants to play 91 which
pretty much shows that it's probably
lost here wookie 3 is just winning out
right here because of this double check
this is really too much
you know what can I give this check but
after this he's out of moves
yeah if not this is this piece sacrifice
it seems as it's just just unsound
alright thanks for watching